[Applaudissements]
j'ai évidemment regardé son match de
simple et son match de double c'est une
vraie fierté pour nous parce qu'en fait
il a eu un comportement exemplaire il a
deux balles de set au second j'aurais
bien aimé voir un troisième saut aurait
pu basculer
il a été très combatif très vaillants
très concentré très performant en double
et on va dire que c'est c'était une
journée de premiere première sélection
en équipe de france première fois numéro
un de l'équipe deux premières défaites
première défaite en coupe davis première
victoire mais un bilan super positif et
je pense que ça va l'aider encore à
passer un cap
pour bien connaître arthur depuis
maintenant assez longtemps et c'est
quelqu'un qui adore le collectif il a
commencé quand il était plus jeune par
beaucoup joué au foot et puis il a tout
il n'a jamais raté un match par équipe
c'est quelque chose qu'ils adorent ils
adorent partager et je pense que c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles il
ya aussi vite progresser
si on doit faire un bilan de la saison
d'artur mas il passe en deux ans la 365e
place à la 58e c'est assez exceptionnel
c'est un des joueurs qui a gagné le plus
de matches sur le circuit professionnel
cette année
c'est un bilan très positif et j'espère
qu'il va continuer sur cette lancée
arthur sait pas que c'est quelqu'un qui
digérera à mon avis très bien et très
vite il a des objectifs de progrès qui
vont déboucher sur des objectifs de
résultats dont je suis absolument pas
inquiet il ira au bout de ce qui peut
faire et je pense qu'il n'a pas encore
atteint ce justement ce bout là